bonsoir j'espère que vous avez passé un
bon weekend et bienvenue sur TV fil 78
pour cette première édition du journal
pour cette semaine invité de cette
édition jean- y petit directeur du
comité des ivelines de prévention
routière en cette rentrée une campagne
de sensibilisation autour des piétons et
lancé en 2012 36 jeunes de moins de 15
an ont été tués en France nous
reviendrons aussi sur ce weekend
meurtrier dans les ivelines de motards
ont perdu la vie le 6 septembre 2014
marque le centenaire du début des
batailles de la Marne c'était en 1914
partout en France une centaine d' de
héros honorés dans les ivelines c'est à
Versailles qui a eu lieu la
commémoration pour se souvenir des
soldats du 5e régiment de G en tennis de
table la proie attend le club d'élencour
premier match à ce niveau demain mardi
soir quelles sont les chances de
l'équipe
locale nous débutons par ces deux fits
divhivers tragique vendredi soir vers
20h45 c'est un accident mortel qui a eu
lieu près de la commune de Manil hamoau
un motard a perdu la vie il circulait
sur la départementale 195 et aurait
perdu le contrôle de son véhicule avant
d'être éjecté après avoir heurté le bas
côté de la route un témoin présent a
tenté de lui faire un massage cardiaque
mais d'après la police le motard roulait
trop vite il aurait été tué sur le cou
les gendarmes de manilamo sont chargés
de l'enquête ils attendent pour
l'instant les résultats des prélèvements
sanguins pour détecter une éventuelle
présence d'alcool et puis à Rambouillet
cette aut re drame Perre de famille de
40 ans qui circulait lui aussi à moto a
été percuté cette fois-ci de pH par un
automobiliste de 18 ans qui tentait un
dépassement malgré une ligne blanche le
motard est décédé l'automobiliste a été
placé en garde à vue bonsoir jeanrif
petit bonsoir Je vous demandé forcément
votre sentiment vous qui êtes en charge
de la prévention routière dans dans le
département à l'annonce de ces deux
accidents tragiques de ce weekend et ben
c'est bien triste et je présente mes
condoléances évidemment aux familles aux
familles des deux
victimes ma réaction c'est que moi je je
l'ai appris comme vous aujourd'hui euh
on voit que dans les deux cas il y a
quand même de l'imprudence h dans l'un
des deux cas une vitesse
excessive
automilisteouou oui et dans l'autre
dépassement dangereux de la part d'un
d'un automobiliste donc de toute façon
dans les deux cas il y a eu un un
comportement dangereux soit de la part
de la victime soit de la part de de
celui qui a causé l'accident mais une
imprudence qui aurait probablement pu
être évitée h et et l'accident les
accidents ainsi évités c'est bien
malheureux ça veut dire qu'il faut
renforcer la prévention la sanction
aussi c'est toujours le même discours
bien sûr il faut renforcer la prévention
mais la prévention ne marche que si les
gens y croient et l'écoutent et après
c'est soit l'accident lui-même et là on
a PR on on prend conscience
effectivement quand on subit un accident
ou quand on cause un accident et ben que
c'est grave euh ou sinon c'est
évidemment les forces de l'ordre qui qui
sanctionnent jusqu'à présent les
chiffres de la sécurité routière dans le
département était plutôt encourageant
jusqu'à ces ces deux accidents
concernant les motards tout d'abord
alors j'ai
euh j'ai j'ai pas tant de détails que ça
je sais que dans le depuis le début de
l'année le dans notre département nous
sommes pas dans la tendance générale de
l'État enfin de de la France pardon
puisque il y a moins de tuer dans notre
département que l'année dernière alors
que d'une au niveau national c'est
l'inverse euh cette année donc
aujourd'hui
en ajoutant les deux enfin sans compter
les deux tués on va s'arrêter au 31 août
et il y avait eu 27 tué dans notre
département depuis le début de l'année
alors que l'année dernière pour la même
période il y en avait 33 ça reste des
chiffres relativement petits mais malgré
tout c'est une diminution assez nette ça
s'explique par la météo les gens sortent
moins ou pas fait beau pendant l'été
exactement alors au moins pour le mois
de juillet parce que pour le mois d'août
comme vous savez les l'état comptabilise
les les morts à 30 jours c'estàd les
gens qui décèdent 30 jours après un
accident donc on est obligé d'attendre
un mois supplémentaire pour avoir les
statistiques donc nous avons eu très
récemment les chiffres du mois de
juillet et le mois de juillet a été
étonnamment le mois le moins meurtrier
depuis
1954 et ça a été un des mois de juillet
les plus mossades hein sur le plan de la
la météo depuis enfin depuis de
nombreuses années hein donc les gens
sortent moins à pied vélo en moto donc
il y a moins de gens sur la voie
publique donc statistiquement évidemment
moins de risque d'avoir des accidents
jeanve petit vous êtes venu ce soir nous
parler de prévention routière mais plus
particulièrement des efforts pour
sensibiliser les piétons les jeunes
piétons une semaine après les rentrées
des classes on peut donner ce chiffre
qui ne rassurera pas les familles mais
l'actualité n'est pas toujours souriante
en 2012 en France métropolitaine 36
jeunes piétons de moins de 15 ans ont
été tués 2453 ont été blessés ce sont
des chiffres qui donnent toujours à
réfléchir aux familles quels sont les
accidents les les plus fréquent pour les
piétons ah alors je crois que je l'avais
dit la dernière fois pour les piétons
d'une façon générale les causes
d'accident sont les mêmes que pour les
voitures je parle pas uniquement des
enfants hein c'est-à-dire des
imprudences l'alcool la drogue voir le
téléphone qui est tout aussi perturbant
quand on est à pied que quand on est en
voiture évidemment on va moins vite à
pied mais ce sont les les imprudances
les gens qui traversent la route
n'importe où et cetera donc donc ce sont
les imprudences et pour les enfants les
causes sont un peu différentes on va
peut-être y venir mais il faut quand
même pour rassurer les les parents au
moins dans notre département nous ne
déplorons pas depuis plusieurs années
d'accidents mortels au moins d'enfants
sur le trajet de l'école l'n on parle de
risque piéton à partir de 2 3 ans dès
que les enfant partir moment où il
commence à marcher un petit peu aussi
aller à l'école forcément c'est toujours
la faute des parents un manque de
vigilance il faut une attention
particulière et pour soi et pour ses
enfants à cet âge là c'est évident la
campagne à laquelle vous faites allusion
et que nous lançons que les les
auditeurs les téléspectateurs pour
retrouver dans notre site internet ça ça
saute ça saute sur à l'écran euh
s'adresse bien évidemment aux parents et
euh il leur est expliqué quand il
cliquent quand ils vont un peu dans le
dans le déroul euh toutes les
différences qu'il y a entre un enfant et
un adulte de ce point de vue-là euh et
c'est j'avoue assez intéressant je ne
suis moi-même pas spécialiste de la
petite enfance mais on y apprend ou on y
redécouvre tout le comportement du petit
enfant par tranche d'âge l'enfant a du
mal à anticiper le danger il perçoit mal
les distancer les mouvements il se
repère aussi avec difficulté avec les
les sons tout ça il faut attendre que
l'enfant puisse y faire y faire
attention il y a des facteurs qui sont
importants et il faut faire attention et
les parents doivent être sensibilisés
c'est le message que pass absolument et
et on peut pas leur renseigner aux
enfants tout dès le plus jeune âge quoi
il y a les il y a une l'enfant se
construit petit à petit on ESP comment
on apprend un enfant qu'il faut lui
tenir la main en permanence mais faut
aussi lui expliquer alors tout est
expliqué dans le site internet justement
jusqu'à 5 ans de mémoire peut-être il
faut le tenir par la main lui expliquer
les choses bien évidemment et on peut
commencer à le lâcher à lui lâcher la
main à cet âge là à 7 ans on appelait ça
l'âge de raison je sais pas si si on
l'appelle toujours là il commence à
mieux percevoir les choses son son
environnement à mieux réfléchir aussi et
on estime que il est en pleine session
de ses capacités j'allais dire comme un
adulte presque à l'âge de 11 12 ans en
moyenne comment sensibiliser les enfants
nous sommes allés vous poser la question
dans les rues de 50 ans nel c'est notre
question du
jour de leur faire comprendre
effectivement que B il faut regarder
avant de
traverser de regarder le petit bonhomme
s'il est rouge ou vert et puis également
aussi l'école je pense que c'est très
important qu' sensibilise également les
enfants leur apprendre et que
l'éducation nationale aussi
6 m qu'il en a pas assz non il y a pas
assez de sécurité on fait pas assez de
sécurité au niveau des écoles et les
parents aussi n'en font pas assez donc
il y a des coins qui sont quand même
assez dangereux qu'un enfant ne peut pas
traverser tout seul je sais qu'il existe
un permis vélo qui est organisé par
Guillan cour o o ma grande aussi avait
participé où on avait abordé toutes ces
questions de sécurité routière aussi
donc finalement je crois que c'est un
peu à tout à chacun de il y a beaucoup
d'intervenants finalement qui peuvent
qui peuvent en parler intervenir à
l'école ça c'est quelque chose ce sont
des opérations que vous faites he oui ça
fait partie de notre de notre boulot
effectivement nous intervenons dans les
classes de
CM2 il y a d'autres associations et les
forces de l'ordre la gendarmerie
intervient beaucoup aussi en particulier
dans les zone rurale du département pour
les pour les élèves un peu plus jeunes
ce que ce qu'on appelle le permis piéton
mais nous nous prenons en charge les
enfants au CM2 donc pour le permis vélo
que qu'une des des des auditrices à à
men né nous ne pouvons évidemment pas
faire tout le département
malheureusement nous ne sommes pas assez
nombreux mais nous faisons partie de
ceux qui sont assidus dans les classes
de CM2 pour apprendre aux enfants à être
autonome dans la rue avec leur véloos
vous parliez du vélo justement on va
continuer à par les sécurités routièrees
les incivilités sur la route la police
nationale a lancé une grande opération
de prévention dans les ivelines cette
fois-ci ce ne sont pas les conducteurs
de voitures qui été visé mais bien elle
est cycliste et les piétons trop souvent
impliqué dans les accidents on vient de
le voir reportage réalisé ce matin à
Versailles par Claire Cambier et lodim
moine
le bonjour s'il vous plaîtal
bonjourmar non non non non il était bien
opération de sécurité routière
aujourd'hui à Versailles dans le viseur
des policiers les cyclistes et les
piétons qui commettent des infractions
au code de la route une brigade de se
policiers en civil et en uniforme a été
déployée dans la ville car les risques
restent importants l'année dernière dans
la zone police des ivlines une quinzaine
de piétons et deux cyclistes sont
décédés sur la route pour 2014 le bilan
actuel est de 5 cyclistes et deux
piétons on s'aperçoit que
malheureusement sur le sur le secteur
d'agglomération les grandes villes les
personnes ne ne se respectent plus on
voit le vélo circuler sur le trottoir on
voit le vélo passer le feu rouge le stop
et là il faut dire faut dire à un moment
ben vous commettez une infraction et le
code route s'applique de la même façon
pour vous que pour les voitures feu vert
la voie est libre feu rouge on marque
l'arrêt une règle simple bien trop
souvent autrepassé l'amende forfaitaire
s'élève à 135 € mais aujourd'hui les
policiers proposent une alternative une
formation de sécurité routière de 2h
vous jouez le jeu vous venez si vous
venez pas on vous verbalise ce matin une
dizaine de personnes a préféré cette
option c'est une très bonne initiative
je d'une part pour le portefeuille et
puis pour que ça rentre dans le crâne et
que la prochaine fois les qu'on fasse
plus attention au code de la route
l'opération sera reconduite demain à
Saint-Germain
toujours en plateau pour ce journal du
lundi 8 septembre avec jean-lve petit de
la prévention routière on l'a vu avec ce
sujet bien souvent les règles ne sont
pas respectées par les piétons par les
cyclistes on se sent dégagé de toutes
les règles lorsqu'on est on a oui on a
un peu tendance à penser que le code de
la route ne s'applique qu'aux voitures
alors que l'un des policiers l'a l'a
rappelé le code de la route s'applique à
tout le monde et ce que je disais il y a
5 minutes les causes d'accident pour les
piétons sont les mêmes que pour les
voitures y compris le non respect du de
la route et et les imprudences parfois
euh enfin inexcusable ces dernières
années il y a une explosion du nombre de
vélos forcément avec ces déplacements en
vert on veut faire des des économies et
puis aussi laisser un petit peu sa sa
voiture de côté on change un petit peu
les mentalités ça veut dire que
peut-être qu'à terme il faudrait
développer le PM vélo pourquoi pas ou
est-ce bne ID un vaste sujet là hein
quel est votre regard sur cette question
est-ce qu'il faudrait un permis vélo
pour alors pour les enfants euh nous le
faisons déjà
lesants même si permis n pas pas vraie
valeur légale bien s mais nous le
faisons déjà pour les enfants donc déjà
ça ça mériterait d'être
généralisé par l'Éducation nationale ou
par les ou par les associations
peut-être oui maintenant pour les
adultes je n'ai pas réfléchi
personnellement sur la question ça me
paraît de toute façon assez difficile à
mettre en œuvre ce lorsquon est cycliste
et qu'on commet des des infractions au
code de la route on peut nous retirer
des points sur le permis de conduire ah
non non non il y aucune sanction ah non
non non non non non non alors il arrive
que des policiers ça peut arriver
essaie d'impressionner les gens en leur
disant qu'on va leur retirer les points
mais ça tient pas c'est pas légal quels
sont les quels sont les conseils à donné
en cette rentrée on l'a dit tout à
l'heure les piétons les parents qu'ils
fassent attention à leurs enfants c'est
la période de rentrée scolaire les vélos
également sur les routes pour prudence
toujours toujours pareil je voulais je
voulais ajouter deux petites choses si
vous permettez qui sont développé dans
notre site aussi pour la rentrée il y a
euh il y a quelque chose un concept qui
s'appelle pellbus je sais pas si vous
connaissez ça voilà ce en fait c'est
pour accompagner les enfants à l'école
le matin et les ramener le soir c'est le
même principe qu'une ligne de bus avec
des arrêts euh sauf que euh c'est pas un
bus mais c'est un convoi d'enfant à pied
hein et puis le le chauffeur du bus est
remplacé par les parents qui
accompagnent donc il faut les parents
volontaes on suit le trajet avec les
arrêts du avec les arrêts du pébus les
enfants qui attendent monde dans le
convoi et continue jusqu'à l'école donc
ça ne marche enfin c'est ça me paraît
une bonne idée ça marche dans un certain
nombre de villes du département et de
France ça vient de l'étranger hein mais
ça ne marche évidemment que si les
parents sont volontaires bien sûr et la
deuxième chose si vous permettez bon il
fait encore jour mais assez rapidement
on va arriver à à la nuit aux heures
auxquelles les enfants vont aller ou
rentrer de l'école surtout dans les
zones rurales de notre département il
est essentiel que les enfants soient vus
donc qu'il pent les vêtements clairs si
possible des gilets réfléchissants et
sur leur cartable que les parents
achètent des cartables avec avec des
bandes réfléchissantes soyez prudent
donc pour cette rentré c'est le mot
d'ordre merci jean-f petit directeur du
comité des evvelines de la prévention
routière je rappelle donc que vous
rappelez on s rentrer les familles à
faire attention aussi bien pour les
piétons que pour les cyclistes nous en
parlions vendredi la directrice de
l'hôpital pour enfants malade buon est
actuellement visé par une enquête pour
harcèlement moral envers ses salariés de
nouveaux éléments sont connus
aujourd'hui le point avec Carine
ato que se passe-t-il derrière les
portes de l'hôpital buon un service
hospitalier qui accueille des enfants de
la naissance jusqu'à leur 17 ans mardi 2
septembre la directrice Catherine Pillet
a été placée en garde à vue pendant 20h
à la suite de cinq plaintes déposées
pour arcellement moral les gendarmes
auraient également entendu 45 salariés
de l'établissement selon les syndicats
joints par téléphone et qui ne
souhaitent pas répondre face à la caméra
ces derniers évoquent un climat tendu
depuis l'arrivée de la directrice au
sein de l'hôpital il y a 3 ans ils
avancent plusieurs cas de démission de
collaborateurs un turnover important
relayé dans un courrier adressé à
l'agence régional de santé en juin
dernier et le 22 juillet dernier les
membres du comité hygiène sécurité et
conditions de travail ont d'ailleurs
voté un audit pour une demande
d'expertise des risques psychosociaux
expertise qui se mettra en place en
octobre après sa garde à vue la
directrice de l'établissement a pu
retrouver son poste par la voix de son
avocat Catherine Pillet conteste les
faits qui lui sont reprochés elle parle
même de calomnie et ne souhaite pas
alimenter dit-elle le débat médiatique
et laisse l'enquête suivre son cours
l'hôpital de buulon emploie 350 agents
pour 130 jeunes accueillis depuis sa
nomination Catherine Pillet a lancé une
restructuration de
l'hôpital sans ville sans héros partout
en France en ce mois de septembre a
était célébré le début des batailles de
la Marne pour repousser l'ennemi qui se
trouve alors à ce moment à 50 km de
Paris c'était dans 1914 100 ans plus
tard sans ville s héros ont été choisis
et à Versailles les commémorations se
sont déroulé devant la rue des récolés
Catherine zulato et
antonyche une plaque orne dorénavant la
rue des récolet à versaill elle rend
hommage aux soldats du 5e Régiment du
Génie régiment de chemin de fer parti
combattre en ce 6 septembre 1914 ce sont
les batailles de la Marne décisives pour
le tournant de la première guerre
mondial car ces batailles marquent le
sursaut national ce sursaut national que
nous av avons voulu marquer aujourd'hui
et partant de là il s'agissait de de
tisser le lien avec les les soldats
d'aujourd'hui animé par qui sont animés
par les mêmes valeurs de courage
d'abnégation l'esprit de sacrifice et le
sens du bien commun un hommage appuyé a
aussi été rendu au capitaine André plois
saint-syien fantassin originaire de
Versailles et qui a servi pour ses
batailles où il a d'ailleurs perdu la
vie quand on repense au sacrifice fait
par tous ces jeunes gens entre 1914 et
1918 c'est absolument faramineux 1lion
200000 morts vous rendez compte le fleur
de la jeunesse française 17 ans 18 ans
jusqu'à jusqu'à 50 ans voyez c'était à à
80 % des gens de la terre des
cultivateurs des gens du peuple et ils
aimit leur terre et c'était pour
défendre cette terre et défendre leurs
frères et sœurs leur grand parents ils
avaient ils étaient bien éduqués pour ça
en 1914 le 5e régiment du génie de
Versailles créé en 1889 comprenait 16
compagnies sur rail 16 compagnies de
réserve et quatre compagnies
territoriales c'est l'unique régiment de
sapeur de chemin de
fer Henri Pouillot président de laarac
des ivelines a profité de cette
commémoration du 6 septembre pour
remettre un dossier un courrier à
l'état-major des armées afin de rappeler
ce dossier lié à la guerde Algérie celui
de Maurice odudin mathématicien arrêté
le 11 juin 1957 et que l'on n'a jamais
revu ensuite pour Henri Pouillot qui a
été l'un des premiers à évoquer la
torture en Algérie il faut dire
aujourd'hui toute la vérité sur ce cas
sur cette disparition de Maurice odudan
il était membre du Parti communiste
algérien il il soutenait l'indépendance
algérienne il a été arrêté de TR jours
avant Henri ALG et il est on n jamais
retrouvé Maur saudin la thèse i c'est
qu'il s'était évadé de de à la suite de
son arrestation or on sait de fait que
c'est un assassinat qui pur et simple
qui a été fait il y a plusieurs
témoignages qui vont dans ce sens-l il y
a les aveux quelques quelques mois avant
son décès de du général ozarez il y a
aussi les les archives de du colonel
Godard retrouvé en Californie par la
journaliste de Nathalie funess de Nouvel
Observateur qui euh
évoque l'idée que Maurice souudin était
exécuté par un lieutenant le lieutenant
garcé qui est d'ailleurs encore vivant
en Bretagne qu'on sache exactement dans
comment il a été assassiné qui quel
quels sont les responsables et puis
surtout qu' a une condamnation de la
torture parce que en fait la la France a
toujours pas reconnu tous les crimes
commis pendant la guerre d'Algérie dont
la torture en particulier quoi nous
poursuivons cette édition du Journal du
8 septembre et télévision Canal Plus
consacrera sa prochaine série maison au
château de Versailles plus précisément à
sa construction sous lesgit de Louis XIV
pas encore de date de diffusion mais le
casting finalisé George plagden dans le
rôle du monarque ainsi que l'actrice
césarisé plusieurs fois Dominique Blanc
pour incarner Anne d'Autriche
jalilespert auteur du biopque de Yve
Saint-Laurent sur grand écran réalisera
les premiers épisodes de quoi assurer
une bonne promotion au site touristique
hiblelinois qui a vu sa fréquentation
battre de nouveaux records pendant l'été
tournage toujours mais avec d'autres
moyens cette fois-ci des lycéens de
l'établissement Bascan Bouillet se lance
dans la réalisation d'une série sur
internet dédié au Moyen-Âge six acteurs
des figurants et une équipe technique
tous bénévoles ont finalisé ce tournage
pendant l'été le premier épisode est en
ligne depuis ce weekend ne autres vont
suivre d'ici à janvier l'histoire un
jeune homme se voit transporter par son
téléviseur en plein moyenâ
[Musique]
fantastique vous allez pas me faire de
mal
peut-être reste en arrière et ne bouge
pas où tu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rev alorsess
t'échapperz
avance
et les créateurs de cette websérie
seront invités demain du journal je
recevrai également les organisateurs du
festival 24 au Vélodrome de montiny le
Bretonneux un festival d'envergure
autour des cultures urbaines avec
plusieurs artistes internationaux en
Sport Tennis de table et seulement
quelques heures avant que ne débute la
saison de pro AA le club d'élancour va y
faire ses grands début avec une
confrontation choc dès le premier jour
Antony res
elles n'attendent que ça pour leur
premier match en prois les joueuses
d'lancour auront le droit un baptême XXL
puisque les filles de Fran solniier se
déplacent chez l'islanois tout
simplement le vicechampion de repenti on
est impatient de de voir un petit peu ce
que c'est que que ce championnat de
ProA sans prétension parce que le
championnat va être très dur mais ouais
on a hâte d'être mardi déjà là on parle
que de ça en fin de compte là il y a
vraiment une envie de faire quelque
chose et d'aller chercher le maintien
parce que c'est l'objectif de l'équipe
cette année dans ce championnat pour
décrocher son maintien et après le
départ d'anopijan etencour a fait venir
l'expérimenté slovène ban Todorovic la
médaillée de bronze au Championnat
d'Europe 2005 avait déjà rencontré le
club probé sous les couleurs de quimpè
alors quand le ctte l'a contacté cet été
à 36 ans la nouvelle doyenne de l'équipe
n'a pas hésité très
longtemps j'ai choisi en cour parce que
l'équipe et l'esprit d'équipe c'est pour
moi le plus important c'est cette force
qui nous permettra de gagner des mat et
j'ai logiement trouvé ma place
ici pour la première fois de son
histoire le club va évoluer dans l'élite
du tennis de table français seul Eva
Odorova et Bana Todorovic connaissent
les Jes du championnat de France à 35
ans la capitaine et courtoise ent sa 13e
saison de ProA et fait office de guide
par avec les filles parce que c'est vrai
que l'année dernier par exemple c'était
eux qui m m par untit peu des joue de
parce que je l'ai pas connu et cette
saison ce sera ce sera plutôt moin
j'essaie donner le conseil je j'essayie
leur leur dire comment comment ça se
passe parce que c'est un petit peu
différent par rapport le probet le
mélange entre jeunesse et expérience
semble en tout cas pétiller reste à le
faire exploser face au champion de
France en titre mardi soir en ouverture
du
championnat nous refermons ce journal il
est à revoir dès à présent sur notre
site internet si vous venez de nous
rejoindre je vous rappelle que la
prévention routière lance 7 rentré une
opération de sensibilisationvers les
piétons les plus jeunes en 2012 36
jeunes de moins de 15 ans ont été tués
en France principalement sur le trajet
de l'école prudence également avec les
beau jours qui se poursuivent pour les
motards le weekend a été meurtrié dans
les ivelin deux d'entre eux ont perdu la
vie à maniléamour et à rambouiller
prochaine édition du journal Mardi 18h
pour le direct rediffusion ensuite 19h
22h30 et minuit ce lundi soir vous avez
rendez-vous avec Anthony reche pour la
reprise du 78 sport et puis demain mardi
18h30 dans le 78 politique deux invités
Pierre Bédier le président UMP du
conseil général des ivelines et
Jean-Paul Huchon président PS de la
Région Île-de-France ils évoqueront les
dossiers forts de la rentrée et l'avenir
du territoire du département et de la
région et bien sûr les échéances
électorales à venir à
demain